- [Interviewer] Alright, Chyna.
Chyna, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Chyna] Oakland.
- [Interviewer] Oakland?
And tell me about your family.
You had both your
parents when you grew up?
- My mom died around
when I was like seven.
She died because she,
my dad was beating on her
and stuff, beating her up,
and he ended up killing her,
so now he's in jail for life.
So really I had to go on my own
and do everything on
my own starting at 13.
16 now.
I've been doing this three years.
- [Interviewer] You started
working the streets at 13?
And who raised you?
- Who raised me?
My uncle.
- [Interviewer] Your uncle?
- So I was out here
starting from 13 to now.
Raised in the Nickerson Gardens.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. South Central LA.
- Projects.
- [Interviewer] So you're 16 now?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And so you're
working Figueroa Street?
- Yeah. I work in the 'Ro.
I don't work it as much,
but I work almost like
every night, every day.
It's a struggle.
Like, I would want to get
out of this, like so bad.
It's a lot that comes
with you working on Fig.
You're risking your life every day.
So it's like,
I don't know.
I'm gonna make something out
of myself one day though.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- I'm gonna make something
out of myself one day though.
- [Interviewer] That's good.
You're in school still?
- No, I graduated
because I did homeschool.
So I graduated already.
- [Interviewer] So you're 16,
but you graduated high school already?
You're a good student?
- Yep. I wanted to graduate
early because I know what I do.
And I can't do that at the same time.
And I'm not going to be a fail in life
'cause I want to work on Fig. You know?
So I had to do both at the same time
and that's what I did.
And yeah.
It got me somewhere though.
- [Interviewer] So your
childhood sounds very rough
because you lost your parents.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How was it
after your dad went to prison,
and you lost your mom?
- It was hard because
even though my mom and dad
used to fight a lot,
I was so close with my dad,
and I was so close with my mom.
If my mama didn't have it, my daddy did.
If my daddy didn't have it, my mama did.
So it was like,
it hurt me to see both of them leave me.
It was like, what am I going to do now?
And I got little sisters
that I have to raise.
I got brothers that I got to raise.
I got a kid.
- [Interviewer] You have a child?
- Yeah. He's one.
His name is Ajante.
And yeah, but he's out in Oakland.
- [Interviewer] So he's
in Oakland with, with who?
- He's out there with my grandma.
- [Interviewer] Your grandmother.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So
you're working Figueroa,
do you work with a pimp?
- Yeah, I do.
I've been working for him since I started.
It's been really, it's been pretty good.
He don't.
- [Interviewer] Its a good relationship?
- Yeah. He don't hit you.
He don't.
And I'm a quiet person.
When it comes to him yelling at me,
I don't talk, you know,
do all that reckless stuff and be loud.
I just sit there and be quiet. You know?
'Cause I just be thinking
through my thoughts.
Like, I got so much other shit
that I could be worried about.
That don't phase me.
You know?
- [Interviewer] So he keeps
how much of your money?
- All of it.
But I get anything I want
anytime I want.
And that's what I like about it,
that I get anything I
want, anytime I want.
If I want it, I'm gonna
get it right there,
then and there.
- [Interviewer] So you could
get out if you wanted to?
- Yeah, I can leave if I wanted to.
- [Interviewer] You
choose to stay with him
'cause he's treating you well?
You've been arrested
out there on the street?
- Yep, I have.
Tickets and all,
but they don't really
bother me no more as much.
Unless it's, you know, Vice
day or Tuesday or Thursdays,
they don't really bother me
because I'm not no, like
I don't be out there every single day,
and I don't be naked as
much like that either.
I have class for myself too, so yeah.
But I have been arrested.
I've been arrested for,
not only prostitution,
I've been arrested for stabbing girls,
but it was only for my safety.
I was helping myself, you
know, defending myself.
I done been,
I was held at gunpoint just what?
Three weeks ago by a pimp,
and I thought he was a trick.
It was like a moving on eight.
Me and my wifey,
me and my wifey was on 81st street.
And he was playing as a Mexican,
but he wasn't.
He was a pimp under the
mat, under the helmet,
because he was on a motorcycle.
So after that, I've never
got on a motorcycle again.
I got on the motorcycle,
and we were just supposed to
be going to the Sunrise Motel,
which is my motel that I
was staying at at the time.
And we went past it.
He went on the freeway.
He was driving off fast.
I didn't know what to do.
I was panicking.
He took me to an alley.
He put me at gunpoint.
And the only way I could really,
you know, not get killed is
I had to, I had to do something. So.
- [Interviewer] You've
had other bad experiences
with your, with the Johns you pick up?
- You said what?
- [Interviewer] Have
you had bad experiences
with the guys that pick you up?
- No, not really.
Mexicans,
sometime they do play you.
They say they got this,
but they really don't.
That's why I get my money beforehand now.
Then, I used to like pay it.
I used to charge them by the time,
but now it's like altogether, so.
- [Interviewer] Do you
recall the first time?
You were 13 when you started.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you recall
the first time you did this?
- The first time I did this I was scared.
I was on 66th and Fig,
and you told me, I didn't
know what a pimp was.
I didn't know what a ho was.
I just knew what Fig was.
So I had a friend telling me about it.
So we go on Fig,
and the whole time, this pimp,
I'm thinking like he trying to
be my boyfriend or something,
but it's not even that.
He's hopping out the car on me and stuff.
I'm not, no, I don't know what's going on.
So I'm like, why is he
getting out the car on me?
I'm thinking you about to
snatch me up and stuff,
but they can't touch you.
And if they do, then something gone happen
unless they get away.
But I didn't know what was going on.
And the guy, he, the,
another pimp drove past,
and he was like, well, you out of pocket.
What do you expect them to do?
And I was like, what's out of pocket?
You know?
'Cause I didn't know what that was.
Then my HP, she told me, she was like,
out of pocket is when, you know,
but I didn't have no pimp at the time.
But out of pocket is when
you feeding into a pimp
and his ism and stuff,
fitting into everything he's saying,
paying attention to him.
If you can give him a little
bit of attention, that's out.
They gonna keep turning the corner.
They gonna keep doing everything.
And they're not going to
stop until you either leave,
or if you don't leave, obviously,
you like the attention.
You know?
So I learned to stay in pocket.
- [Interviewer] What the
worst thing about doing this?
- The worst thing about doing this is
I feel like if it's slow or the police,
that's the worst thing about doing this is
the police to me.
Even though like they say,
Oh, the police can't do
nothing to you on these days,
that days, but yeah, that's not true.
They can do stuff to you all they want.
Some of the police is cool.
Like yesterday, I had
a police pull up on me.
He was like, what's up?
I was like, Hey.
He was like, you working on Fig tonight?
I was like, yep.
And he was like, go to Manchester.
I said, Nope.
'Cause.
But yeah, some of the
police do be cool and stuff.
I be on Long Beach Boulevard too,
not just Fig.
- [Interviewer] Is
there several different?
- I be on Long Beach
Boulevard morely at nights
because at night
because I don't want me
risking more of my life on Fig.
That's more of a risk to me.
- [Interviewer] Figueroa I was
the busiest of the streets,
but there's Western, there's Long Beach,
and there's other?
Long Beach Boulevard.
Are drugs a part of your life?
- Yeah. I smoke weed, marijuana.
- [Interviewer] That's it?
- Yeah. That's it.
- [Interviewer] Do you get
depressed sometimes doing this?
- Yeah, a lot of times
because the fact that
I have a little sister
and she's doing it too,
it's like, dang, I could
have taught her way much more
and just, you know,
'cause I was in group
homes and stuff, too.
I would run away from group
homes just to, you know, work.
But as soon as I got out
of that group home stuff,
it was like, God was like,
he was punishing me in
many different ways.
And it was just crazy
'cause it was like, my
sister don't think I love her
because of the stuff that I did.
She don't think I love her.
Me going out on Fig every night,
she don't think I love her.
I wasn't spending time with
her as much as I used to.
Nothing was the same.
So then she started doing it,
and now she think it as,
Oh, I'm with my sister now, but no.
I don't even want her doing this.
And I tell her that all the time,
but I know I didn't listen.
Can't get somebody that
I don't listen to listen
if they, you know, that's not gonna work.
So I try my best, you
know, to give her money
instead of her working for it,
as best as I can.
- [Interviewer] How old is your sister?
- She's 14.
- [Interviewer] And she's working?
Do you think you're
addicted to the fast money?
- Yeah, I am.
- [Interviewer] The lifestyle
of this is so tempting, right?
- It's it's real tempting
because it's fast.
It come up fast, and if
it's slow, it'll pick up.
That's why you keep regulars.
Regulars, all you gotta do is call them.
Come get me on Fig.
Money, you never know
how much you gonna get.
- [Interviewer] Do you ever,
do you ever look back at your
situation and just think,
man, this is crazy that I'm doing this?
- [Chyna] Yeah, because.
- [Interviewer] It's dangerous and its'.
- [Chyna] Before I was doing all this,
I was still going through depression.
I was going through
suicide, mental thoughts.
I was cutting, all that,
all over my arms, everywhere just blood.
And it was like crazy
'cause I was really
going through some stuff.
So me thinking about it now, it's like,
I feel like I changed
because I ain't cut in, what?
Some years.
- [Interviewer] You haven't?
- [Chyna] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] That's good.
- [Chyna] That's hecka good.
'Cause I was doing it constantly.
It was like, I couldn't stop
'cause that's the only thing
that was taking my pain away.
It's not like a smoke at the time.
I wasn't allowed to, so.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have dreams or goals
that you'd like to?
- [Chyna] Yeah. I want to do
makeup, and I want to do nails,
and that's what my,
that's what I want to do.
I'm about to have my own
shop pretty soon here,
a nail salon.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- [Chyna] And it's going to
be a black owned business,
but I'm pretty sure it's
going to be popping.
That's going to be a lot of money.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
- [Chyna] So yeah.
- [Interviewer] That'd be great.
- [Chyna] That is going to be great.
I just got to wait for
all this stuff to open.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. It's
a hard time right now.
Do you think doing this
for the last three years
has changed your personality,
changed the way you are?
- Yeah, it has.
It actually made me a
stronger person because of,
I was weak at the time.
And you know, you,
I mean, not saying weak, I wasn't weak.
It was, I was not in
the right state of mind.
And if you got somebody
that could put you in
a right state of mind,
and you ain't got to worry as much.
So I think I, yeah, I did change a lot.
Like I got more into myself,
more seeing who myself was,
more loving myself.
Even though I'm on Fig, I
still got time to love myself.
And I got somebody telling me
all good thoughts, all good knowledge too.
So I could still overthink
what I did in the past,
think now, and it's like,
okay, I see you trying to.
So it' like.
- [Interviewer] What advice
would you give to a young girl
who's considering doing
something like what you're doing?
- My advice for you is
if you gone do it,
I'm not going to say 'cause anybody,
first time they not gonna
know what they doing,
but if you're going to do it,
make sure you do it right,
and make sure you're not
doing it all your life.
Because if you're doing it all your life,
where are you getting?
You're just giving your
money to the same person.
You're not investing in it.
So my advice for you is
if you're going to do it,
invest in something.
Don't just keep doing it all your life.
'Cause that's out.
That's out.
- [Interviewer] How much do
you think your self-worth,
I mean, that's what you
believe you deserve in life,
plays a part in your decision to do this
and getting your, getting yourself here?
And cause if you believe
you're destined for something better,
you probably wouldn't allow
this to happen, right?
- Yeah, I wouldn't.
So you're saying like.
- [Interviewer] I just wonder,
I wonder if like, you know,
you had a rough childhood
because you lost your parents,
and sometimes if you're not
supported the right way,
you end up feeling like you don't deserve
better things in life.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] I mean, it
sounds like you have a good head
on your shoulders.
'Cause you're looking to get out,
you're looking to do something
productive and that's great.
And you've finished school early,
which is really remarkable.
So there's a lot of, a
lot of positives I see.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] But I just, I just wonder
if there was something that
brought you down this path.
- What brought me down this
path is the group of friends
I was hanging around.
- [Interviewer] Oh, your friends?
- Yeah.
But I didn't know about nothing
about hoing, pimping, Fig,
none of that til I started hanging around
with them group of friends.
And I thank them group of friends sometime
because it got me somewhere,
and some of them friends is still here.
I only got what, two
friends that still here?
Other ones, they ran off.
You know?
- [Interviewer] So you
had a lot of friends
that do this as well?
- Yeah. I mean, not really friends.
I got home girls.
I don't do friends.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- It's family.
- [Interviewer] Do you have any friends?
- I got friends, yeah.
But they don't do Fig and stuff.
I got one friend that do Fig,
and she barely be over there.
But.
- [Interviewer] How much
money do you make in a night?
- In a night, I say like,
if you are working on Fig,
by the end of the night,
you'll have, what?
700, 800, if you doing it right.
Or 500, if you're doing it right.
But the most I've made in
one night is four racks.
- [Interviewer] Is what?
- Is four racks.
- [Interviewer] You've
been 4,000 in a night?
- Yes. In one night.
You gotta have a good mouthpiece,
otherwise trick's not going to date you.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So when
the guys pick you up,
you go to the hotels?
You go to the car?
- You can do car dates.
You can do hotels.
I, yeah.
Really, I like move it in more to the car
instead of going to a hotel.
- [Interviewer] It's faster?
- It's faster.
And if they want to go to a hotel,
I charge them more.
And they do it, too.
- [Interviewer] So how many guys will you
do this with in a night?
- I say like five, for real, for real.
If you keep, like, Oh, not even, not five.
Maybe 10, maybe, you know,
somewhere near a lot,
but not a lot.
Not a lot.
Because you can get
money out of one person
over and over and over and over again.
You don't got to go to the next person
and wait for the next person.
- [Interviewer] Are
you ever tricking guys,
where you're getting them
to give you money?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And not
having sex with them.
- I use the finesse. But.
- [Interviewer] That's
part of the game, right?
- Yeah. It's part of the game.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- They can't do nothing to
you if you walk out the door.
What they going to do?
- [Interviewer] There's a
reason they're called tricks,
right?
- Tricks. You're a trick.
I tricked you.
You know, so yeah.
- [Interviewer] Does
this, has this changed
the way you view men, you think?
- Yes. It has a lot
because you would never think,
like a pimp is really a pimp.
Like, you might hear it in songs.
I used to hear it in songs
and not know what it is but be saying it.
And now I know.
And it's like, dang.
I was saying all that?
Look where I ended up.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
I mean, so the pimps today,
they're not driving the
big Cadillacs and the,
and the flashy clothes,
they're more undercover?
The modern ones, right?
And do they almost look
like they're boyfriends
when they're coming at you
and then all of a sudden you realize
that you're giving them their money?
- No. 'Cause when you,
now that I'm been doing this for so long,
I know when a pimp is a pimp.
I know when you just say
you're a drug dealer,
some of the pimps try to play,
Oh, I'm just a drug dealer.
Nah.
As soon as I see a black person,
I don't care what it is,
I walk away.
Unless you a old black man, I'll date you,
but if you not, then no way.
- [Interviewer] You stay
away from black guys
for that reason?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] They're
always playing games?
Alright, Chyna.
Well, thank you so much
for talking with me.
- You're welcome.
- [Interviewer] And good
luck with your, your dreams.
That'd be great to get out
and do something like that.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You seem like you got
the ability to do that.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] It'd be cool to see.
Alright. Thank you.
- Bye.